[Musica]
questa bicicletta sono sei bici diverse
il telaio è stato trovato in una cantina
appartiene una bici degli anni 50 i
freni arrivano da un'altra bici le ruote
arrivano dal centro raccolta rifiuti di
via arbe la sella da una bici
incidentata e l'unico pezzo che si è
salvato oltre al conducente
per fortuna il manubrio è un regalo di
un ex campione di ciclismo che oggi ha
80 anni gomme camere d'aria sono nuove
quando le nostre bici non ci servono più
sono rotte possiamo portarle in un
centro di raccolta dove verranno
smaltite come ferrovecchio oppure donate
alla cooperativa che si occupa del
centro di riuso dove le smontano e
riparano le vivendo
stiamo parlando di riparazione e riuso
niente di eccezionale in fondo da
qualche anno la lm cartour fondation
soprattutto ha dato un nome a una serie
di azioni che hanno qualcosa in comune
con la costruzione di questa bici
frankestein economia circolare per quale
motivo lo fa è perché per noi è
importante cominciare a ragionare in
questi termini
normalmente gli oggetti che utilizziamo
ogni giorno sono progettati secondo uno
schema lineare
prendiamo la materia prima la
trasformiamo per costruire qualcosa che
quando non ci servirà più
andrà a smaltimento nello schema
dell'economia circolare invece
continuiamo a costruire i nostri oggetti
sempre utilizzando lo stesso stock di
risorse
la premessa dell'economia lineare che le
risorse siano infinite a buon mercato si
è rivelata falsa
gli oggetti sono progettati per rompersi
e il mercato è costituito da individui
come me
sempre in cerca dell'ultimo modello di
cellulare però è più green non funziona
non riusciamo a recuperare tutti i 4
miliardi di tonnellate di rifiuti che
produciamo ogni anno e a ridargli nuova
vita con l'economia circolare invece
cambia tutto perché ad esempio
cominciamo a focalizzare l'attenzione
più sull'uso che sulla proprietà
pensiamo alle automobili
cosa accade se invece se sono usate da
10 o 12 utenti diversi
allora avremo bisogno di meno automobili
e cambia anche il modo in cui le
scegliamo io per esempio mi sento molto
figo quando col car sharing posso
scegliere ogni volta il tipo di auto di
cui ho bisogno in quel momento e questo
vale per l'auto vale per la bici vale
per molti altri oggetti
cos'è dunque l'economia circolare è
un'immagine che ci consente di stabilire
connessioni nuove tra i prodotti i
servizi e le persone quello del riuso e
della riparazione è un modello di
business interessante
i centri di riuso per me non sono i
luoghi della sfiga
dove vai a comprare roba vecchia a basso
prezzo
sono piuttosto i luoghi dove gli oggetti
hanno di nuovo valore
i veri luoghi della sfiga per me
sono le cantine gli armadi cassetti dove
stupiamo gli oggetti che non usiamo più
quegli oggetti sono privi di valore
perché non servono più a nessuno buona
parte di oggetti che utilizziamo ogni
giorno possono essere riparati però la
riparazione costa per questo in svezia
hanno dimezzato l'iva sulle riparazioni
e gli oggetti possono essere costruiti
meglio per essere riparati per quale
motivo è così difficile sostituire il
disco fisso di un computer con uno nuovo
più potente gli elettrodomestici tanti
altri beni possono essere ricondizionati
ad esempio caterpillar ritira i mezzi di
movimento terra sostituisce le parti
usurate verifiche al funzionamento delle
parti più resistenti li rivende a metà
prezzo con la stessa garanzia del nuovo
c'è poi il modello della filiera
circolare noi produciamo tutti noi
produciamo scarti in cucina che
attualmente vanno in discarica oppure
diventano gas e terriccio
ma se ne trasformiamo una parte in
bioplastica che diventa imballaggi per
il nostro sistema distributivo e poi
questi imballaggi giunti a fine vita
diventano mangime per i nostri animali
scarti di cucina bio plastiche
imballaggi mangime per animali
allevamento produzione di cibo scarti di
cucina e così via all'infinito
oppure un altro modello è quello del
prodotto come servizio per quale motivo
dobbiamo ogni volta acquistare lampadine
lampadari
tutto quello che ci serve a illuminare
quando possiamo stipulare un contratto
con un'azienda che installa l'impianto è
che ne resta proprietaria nel momento in
cui qualcosa si rompe manderà un addetto
che ripara o sostituisce e interesse del
fornitore in quel caso che i beni che ci
fornisce siano durevoli riutilizzabili
riciclabili e al risparmio energetico
tanto la quota che noi paghiamo ogni
mese sempre la stessa come accade già
all'aeroporto di schiphol in olanda
e poi c'è ci sono le piattaforme di
condivisione il car sharing il bike
sharing che poi è un modello antico le
biblioteche in fondo sono delle
piattaforme di condivisione del libro
esistono anche esempi molto semplici se
per esempio una gelateria a bologna che
vende il gelato sfuso dentro barattoli
di vetro quando devi riacquistarlo
restituisci il barattolo di vetro ti
fanno uno sconto fidelizzano e non usano
plastica o un produttore di scarpe
marchigiano che utilizza le pezze
avanzate alle aziende più grandi
i teorici dell'economia circolare in
questo caso parlano di aziende
simbiotiche e c'è un'azienda a cuneo che
produce materiale da sabbiature dalle
nocciole perché sono scabrose cuneo
nocciole gianduiotti sabbiature e così
via
sia chiaro qualsiasi processo produttivo
produce scorie
tuttavia in un sistema circolare le
scorie sono una sfida all'intelligenza
di ognuno di noi abbiamo intravisto cosa
vuol dire economia circolare focalizzare
l'attenzione più sulla relazione tra le
parti che sul prodotto
pensiamo all'edilizia
se tutti gli edifici fossero smontabili
e le parti rimontabili riutilizzabili
altrove come in un gigantesco leggo
eppure un po quello che è successo con
lo stadio delle alpi smontato e
rimontato per realizzare il nuovo stati
abbiamo l'intelligenza per farlo abbiamo
le tecnologie per farlo e nel 2015
l'unione europea ha dichiarato di voler
diventare un sistema economia circolare
entro il 2035
ce la faremo
molto dipende dalla lungimiranza delle
classi dirigenti è un po dipende anche
da noi
ognuno di noi può cominciare a pensare
in termini di durata
di riuso di uso invece che di possesso
prendiamo questi jeans li ho presi in
leasing pago 7 euro e 50 al mese per un
anno
e quando non mi serviranno più li
restituirò ai legittimi proprietari che
li potranno rivendere come beni usati
oppure portare a riciclaggio
e interesse del produttore che il
materiale sia di buona qualità affinché
mantenga il suo valore nel tempo gli
oggetti che usiamo ogni giorno sono
miniere
anche questa bici le camere d'aria
quando saranno troppo vecchie per essere
riparate potranno ancora essere utili a
marco e laura che ne faranno borse
portafogli cinture che vendono in tutto
il mondo grazie al web
io mi sento fortunato perché vivo in un
tempo in cui un cambiamento radicale è a
portata di mano basta volerlo che ne
dite
ci proviamo grazie